il leur reste encore huit mois pour être
prêt en décembre prochain le vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le futur
clairefontaine du cyclisme français doit
ouvrir officiellement ses portes ce 23
avril une étape décisive a débuté la
dalle de béton de l'air centrale est en
train d'être coulé sur plus de 2700
mètres carrés cet espace est essentiel
car il va servir de base aux
constructeurs de la piste au dessus de
nos têtes on a à peu près mille tonnes
d'acier ce qui est quand même assez
important c'est quoi c'est pas très
courant même en ile de france
cette charte en toi est terminée depuis
maintenant quelques semaines la
couverture également est en passe d'être
d'être terminée voilà on commence un peu
à voir la forme finale du vélodrome dont
la configuration compétition près de
5000 spectateurs pourront garnir les
gradins du vélodrome les responsables du
chantier sperl livrée clé en main à
l'automne ou la touche finale sera
évidemment la piste en bois il est prévu
que le constructeur de la piste elle
arrive à partir de début août donc les
toutes premières lattes seront posées à
partir du 12 août très précisément tout
cas c'est comme ça qu'on a vu dans le
calendrier est donc la fin de la piste
c'est un sapin pour ce qui est de la
partie plus visible le vélodrome est en
train de revêtir sa robe finale le
bardage extérieur juste derrière
d'autres équipes sont en train d'établir
les fondations de la future piste de bmx
au total 140 personnes travaillent sur
le chantier la naissance de ce complexe
sportif inédit coûtera près de 70
millions d'euros